today i'm crafting with two of the
youngest members of our team
it's bring your child to work day and i
want you to meet
layla and haley
now layla's dad is actually
our show's phenomenal director adam
that's right and haley's mom
is the associate director the one and
only sarah
and they are in our control room
now it's been a busy year at our show
and i wanted to give their parents a
little break but mostly i just wanted to
hang out with
haley and layla hi girls hi hi how are
you today
i'm good how's home school going you
sick of it
yeah oh gosh 15 months oh
wow good counting
yeah i'm are you ready to go back to
actual school
yeah i'm probably going on the 19th of
april again
really good numbering you know what i
would give for my kids to know their
calendar they all tease me about the
calendar because i love my camera
and how are you feeling about school
good yeah and are you do you feel like
you're
learning in virtual school well i'm in
school full
time and um i already know lots of stuff
that
they're teaching us in school so you're
in school
and you're one smarty pants aren't you
you know what
you remind me exactly of your mother
because she is so confident and she
knows how to get her job done
and we all look to her to get it done
because
confidence is a very wonderful quality
in someone
that's your mom she's the one who says i
know what to do oh i'm so happy to be
doing this with you guys
all right so now we're going to get into
some crafting one of the places
that i have gone to with my daughters
throughout our whole lives
is a very important place in new york
it's called the craft studio and
it's a female-owned new york city-based
business that provides kids
with craft parties classes and art
workshops
i'll tell you this my daughters have
never had a birthday party
that didn't involve the craft studio and
i would like
to meet our instructor she happens to be
someone i know and love
it's the craft studios lindsay pierce
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to be here
what are we making today i love it so we
are making these beautiful tissue paper
flowers you guys all have in front of
your desk look how fun okay
first for parents and kids at home we
have a quick
clip to show you how to get started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i love that okay does everyone have
their kit in front of them let's get
started
are you ready to rock guys yeah i'm
excited okay
so starting on the bottom layer like
you're holding it like a stem
good job okay perfect we're gonna open
and bloom
our flower we're going to open it up so
it forms like a
half circle on each side and you're
going to slowly
separate the tissue paper layers
and it's like a flower coming to life
in bloom so go around and around
and what i love about this project is
it's so much fun for littles but also it
looks so beautiful
and elegant and it could be on your
table at a centerpiece of
a beautiful dinner party we all hope to
have soon oh i love a tablescaping item
yeah right isn't that cool do your
parents ever ask you to help set the
table
yeah uh um i love your reaction really
you're like
i know maybe from now on they can help
you to ask
like do the uh table flower oh yeah
i know and you can make them for any
season which is so fun that's right you
could do like
red green and white for christmas you
could do
uh autumnal colors for thanksgiving yes
you can make a little
fourth of july warm and cold colors
that's right and fourth of july there
that the possibilities are
endless endless possibilities and you
saw in the piece how we frayed the
different edges you can get
funky with that when you're putting your
tissue paper together
i love it yeah that is so fun oh
beautiful look at that
you can accessorize oh my goodness layla
it's fantastic
haley let's see yours oh oh my god you
guys
have done such an amazing job you know
layla i think yours
really reminds me of like a lily pond
that sort of has a beautiful
pokey uh petals in the center and
yours looks sort of very wide and
sunflowery
right i know yeah exactly floating on a
river
exactly haley and layla i'm so happy
that we got to do crafts with you today
let's please do this again well i know
where to find your parents
and lindsay thank you so much you've
been such a good friend over the years
and i just love the fact that the craft
studio is in our small business
guide and we promote it the craft studio
is here in new york and it really is a
great place for families to go
oh thank you for being a champion for
all small businesses and i love
creating magic with you you bring so
much magic everywhere thank you drew
thank you lindsay don't be surprised if
this is strapped to my next outfit